I win dude I just made out with Jamie
hurt this is great and then that was it
wait what did I just made out with Jamie
makers nope our eyes and ears aren't
deceiving us that was Chad Michael
Murray confessing he once played tonsil
hockey with Jamie Lee Curtis the
Riverdale star dropped the bombshell on
busy tonight Thursday revealing that the
big smooch went down in 2003 when Jamie
and Chad were filming at the Disney
flick Freaky Friday with Lindsay Lohan
Chad says Lindsay Lohan had never been
kissed and was nervous about locking
lips for the cameras that's when Jamie
stepped in to save the day
I was um Lindsay Lohan's first kiss and
Jamie Lee Curtis was there and she was
trying to kind of settle the situation
because Lindsay's nerves were a little
bit you know all the place as you would
assume right your first kiss you're like
16 years old at the time Lindsay was 16
Chad was 21 and Jamie was drumroll
please 44 Jamie's Nygaard didn't get her
my trailer come on so we go when we sit
in Jamie's trailer and she's talking to
Lindsay trying to get her to just kiss
him come on just give him pop kisses no
big deal it's break thanks now she goes
all come on and she's crashing by the
back ahead and makes out with me in love
and at this point I win dude I just made
out with Jamie Curtis this is great and
then that was it yeah yeah yeah
[Applause]
do we love this story do we it seems all
kinds of weird and a little aft of to me
this is yesterday was freaky and I mean
I see your mom and I like I mean like
her like your mom just in case you
missed this epic moment in pop culture
here is what you need to know Lindsey
plays Jamie's daughter the to get in an
argument and they switch bodies only to
come to a better understanding about
each other and switch right back I know
we seem to be oh I beg your pardon
yeah it sounds totally weird but trust
me it's actually a really great movie
and whatever kind of magic Jamie was
leaving in that trailer it worked
Lindsey and Chad's movie kiss was one
for the books no thinking about that
kiss
[Music]
money again how I did it
[Music]
alright guys I've come around I changed
my mind
I don't blame Jamie for seizing that
moment because Chad Michael Murray is so
fine of course over here to keep you up
to date on all things Chad and his new
role in Riverdale so be sure to
subscribe to all things et until next
time I'm Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]